nickels congratulations you made it to
the final round of the beat the unbeaten
competition
now up till now ben has faced multiple
smiths
and he's knocked him all out
it's all up to you in order to take home
the title you're gonna have to go
against the unbeaten smith himself ben
abbott
i've known nicholas for years so seeing
him standing there i'm not surprised
he's a very talented smith now nicholas
because you are the challenger here you
got to choose any weapon you wanted from
the fortune fire vault ben you're ready
to find out what that is
you are both going to have to complete
this
the spatha
the spot the sword dates back to 3rd
century rome this cavalry weapon
features a straight double-edged blade
that allows for deeper deadlier cuts and
thrusts than the shorter gladius sword
previously used by the roman soldiers
first featured in season 7 of fortune
fire two smiths impressed the judges
with their ornate versions of this blade
however once in its failure to include
one of the parameters a medal ridge cost
him the competition
so good luck your time starts now the
most critical part of this build is
right now if i don't get these four
drills right
yeah it's gonna break
my force four drill went perfect second
one went great i'm really happy these
bullets are looking really really good
both my bullets are forge welded and
pulled out to a really nice dimension
i'm really happy with them and i'm ready
to go twist
nicholas is using the press as a vice
and getting his first twist going
the second piece is ready and i start my
twist to the left
i get about two turns in
and i realize i'm twisting it the same
direction so i try to counter twist it
back to get it straight
and it starts to pull my billet apart i
need to start this billet over after all
the work that i've done so far there's
no way i'm going out on a parameter
there is no saving that billet the welds
have opened all i can think of is how am
i going to make up this time i got to
start over
it's the moment of truth
all i can think counterclockwise
counterclockwise
everything goes perfect i'm really happy
the quench went well i'm feeling pretty
good i think i've managed my time well
enough but i have a lot of grinding to
do
i'm doing flat grind with an apple seed
edge i find that this one for most of
the test performs the best
i'm trying to clean up the display get
some linseed oil on the handle so at
least i can have something presentable
today has been the hardest day foraging
i think i have ever had
i feel a lot of pressure for this being
my last one i really want to leave on a
high note i know nicholas is really good
so i really want to win but this is a
rough one
now is the time to start twisting this
bullet
so i make sure my first bullet i twist
counterclockwise because that way if i
get lazy or if i get i'll accidentally
turn the other one the right way
i just start twisting and twisting i
want really tight bars because i think
that the pattern at the end is going to
look phenomenal
now i have my second billet out i start
twisting it clockwise
it's going to take one or two more heats
to get it just to where i want it but
it's coming along great
as i'm looking down it looks good to me
just a round cap at the end would have
been okay but this just adds a little
piece of panache at the top of this
sword that i think really looks amazing
i think it's gonna work really well as a
counterbalance so i'm gonna go above and
beyond and try to make this thing
gorgeous
five four
three
two
one placements put down your tools turn
off the machines this eight hour round
is over late smith's welcome to the
dynamic keel test
so i'm gonna deliver some slashes of
thrust on this big carcass and try to
cut through these tatami mats the blue
anvil is up first
all right gentlemen first up when you're
looking at this handle here because it's
a forward weight on the sword there's no
counter balance here that
every time i'm swinging this
the blade wants to leave my hand
but
this cuts onto the pig carcass are very
deep but overall this weapon
it will kill the bar has been set really
high i just hope mine can match it
all right gentlemen so the balance of
this blade is back toward the handle so
it's easier to control
the edges took no damage
on the pig carcass the weight
distribution of slashing with this
actually cuts very deep overall this
weapon
it will kill
all right gentlemen it's time for our
dynamic strength and sharpness test the
clay pot smash and fish slice
this is all about the edge retention of
your blade how well they cut and how
well they feel in my hand so gentlemen
it's time to start
[Music]
[Music]
all right so it held its edge which is
great the weight's not an issue other
than once you finish a swing the
recovery is a little bit slower but it
held up well good job
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right so right off when i pick up
this sword what i feel more than
anything is the balance you want that
balance point right there the pattern is
beautiful the edge held up really well
and cut well and though i love the
attempted historical accuracy in this
handle it would have been nice to see a
little bit more finish work done on it
having said that when i put it in my
hand it fits really nicely it's nicely
done
well blade smith it comes down to this
final moment you both did a phenomenal
job judges agree both your blades tested
almost evenly so it came down to the
very finest of details the stakes are
really high ben if you win you will
remain undefeated and go to a record of
nine wins and zero losses our judges
discussed your blade and they came out
with a final conclusion and the winner
of today's fortune fire competition is
he has done it again ben abbott
congratulations oh my god oh my god
congratulations oh my god nicholas
unfortunately your blade didn't come out
on top today you smoked the competition
you did a phenomenal job here but
unfortunately at this time i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor thank you guys very much
thank you so much senior nice job man i
did my best ben came out on top totally
deserves a win
ben abbott we are running out of fingers
to count on you are the champion again
9-0 buddy how do you feel i feel amazing
so much of me has gone into it
blood-wise but i'm just super jealous
that it paid out i just became the
fortune fire champion again
i am just elated this is probably one of
the best experiences of my life to go
through five competitions and win all
five of them in a row the blade i'd say
right now that's the most stunning
pattern that you've presented in each of
these competitions i've learned a little
bit of something you have to learn how
to be fast you have to learn how to be
good you have to learn how to be smart
and i just feel like my skill is getting
better and better as i go where do you
go from here
dave you ready to compete
sign me up oh hell yes
i'm currently 9-0 i'm unbeaten if you
think you got what it takes bring it on
i'm ready
you